[Music]
all right this is pretty trippy a
six-year-old girl that went missing
since 2019 has been found underneath a
harry potter style hiding place
underneath the stairs
whose stairs are these alive the same
house alive and well in the same house
she's been sneaking out to get food and
stuff this is stockholm syndrome by
proxy oh that's interesting you mean
like self self willing so this six year
old girl she vanished um she was with a
uh
she she was with a legal guardian that
was not her biological parents so i
guess her biological parents lost
custody of her through something there's
no reason shown
and they were suspecting that the
biological parents stole her back so
they kept coming over to try to like
find her
they got reports that oh that i think
there's a kid in there but like no one
could ever find her for two years
so every time the um the investigators
would come and look for it they would
hide her underneath the stairs and the
stairs would like fold up whoa
so she had her own bedroom and all that
she didn't she didn't live in the harry
potter bedroom yeah so they they had her
own her bedroom was there and everything
but then when asked they're like we're
just waiting for her to come back they
would yeah they would go oh we want it
do we want to preserve it for when she
like returns to us
why were they hiding her again because
they're not supposed to have customers
they're not supposed to have they lost
custody of their daughters do you know
why they lost custody there's nothing
like that were they like on crackers
sounds pretty intense customers wait did
they do they treat the their biological
daughter
well
like is that why she never complained or
she's because she's six and like she's
she misses her parents yeah so that's
the stuff but no like do they did they
only hide her when
like child protection services came out
that's what it sounds like i feel like
she was like a normal kid did you go to
school obviously no no so uh during
search of the property the detective
noticed something about the staircase
leading to the back residence that
caught his attention he was shining a
flashlight between the steps and then he
saw her feet oh no way
her foot was just poking
out that's nuts so the father the mother
and the grandfather all conspired
together to hide their daughters
what uh where is this
this is in the uk wait no no it's not
the uk i'm sorry it's uh because i feel
like no matter what yeah
oh it's in new york okay new york if you
get your kid taken away from you and
you're the biological parents you must
be [ __ ] up we're [ __ ] up somewhere
you're you're [ __ ] up a lot so did
the foster parents or her new parents
think she was dead for two years that's
wild i'm sure they probably did yeah but
i think
it sounded like everyone was thinking
that biological parents kidnapped her
but they couldn't prove it yeah you know
what's amazing well they were right
this is when i laugh that's like you
hear about all these these police
departments that have tanks and stuff
like that and like they didn't have a
pair of like heat vision goggles they
could just walk in there and just that's
what we need bro they'd be like she's
right there let's go that's cause you
can't you can't solve you can't solve
the missing kid with a tank
but i'm like dude a tank is expensive
what do you think about mug shot of the
mom who's who uh jacked her
she looks smug look at that smirk where
is it
she looks like a russian spy kinda looks
like dobby yeah she does she does very
harry potter themed did they say like
how they kidnapped her or just probably
said hey come with me and they're like
you want to go to mcdonald's and like
that you want to come live with mommy
and daddy he was like yeah that was it
dude she was six it's probably super
easy you're like hey your parents want
you back okay yeah yeah yeah yeah i'm
just curious like how
the the adopted parents let her out of
her sight
i mean that's it's called kid jack i was
like do you want someone [ __ ] up
it's hard to compete with like
biological parents
like if she misses her parents they
could just roll up to the window
right outside cornell university oh no
way all asians know about cornell
university oh yeah for sure we all know
i heard of it but i don't know where it
is never heard of it is it in cornell
it's in new york yeah
so the college that in the city
yeah so they got her and uh
pretty interesting
under the stairs well all that you know
it wasn't like a nice um hiding place by
the way like when they got in there it
was all dingy and there were blankets
that were soaked it was like i mean
that's where you want to hide them
though the place that they wouldn't look
you wouldn't store a kid but dude that's
a great detective right
unless for two years he missed it yeah
see that's the other thing to go to like
two years he goes oh the stairs
like what is that is that like you're
just a really persistent
task force are you just really bad at
your job or it's like oh i think they're
gonna be over here so we're gonna spend
all our resources looking for this child
not in this home we're gonna look over
here but they went back to the same
house over and over it's kind of like
when you lose your keys right and you
keep looking at the same places and
you're like [ __ ] i know it's here and
then you're like i was in my pocket but
there's a feeling in that house tile and
airtight that's why i'm gonna tile my
child tile your child oh oh yeah yeah
i'm a gps my my kids i got lost at the
heathrow heathrow airport london airport
when i was
five with my mom going to india with my
sister who was like four you were lost i
didn't i didn't get lost
i wasn't lost they lost you you were the
gift shop i was lost according to my mom
and my sister
and um we had me and my sister had these
matching usa uh junior olympic jackets
so fire from taekwondo right here talk
about my sister went to junior olympics
for taekwondo so we had these matching
track jackets from the olympics and so
my mom used to dress us the same so we
could notice this very easy right
my mom couldn't find me for like an hour
and they're like doing the last boarding
call oh [ __ ] to india and my mom started
crying so my mom just sends my sister to
go into the bathroom like the men's
bathroom
and my sister's like ritesh where are
you like screaming like screaming and
they found me at the arcade playing
street fighter
that's like
just having a good old time like my
sister was younger and she was a really
cute kid but apparently the whole time
she was like cursing me out
entire time you don't even remember i
don't really remember but my mom had to
tell my sister like relax
stop saying [ __ ] your brother no like
she's like how could you do this like
you mob my mom i probably never seen my
mom really cry at that point oh [ __ ] i'm
like oh [ __ ] i [ __ ] up
but did you win at street fighter
probably did you finish your round
before you left probably where you get
all those quarries dude this was like 20
years ago longer than 20. it was like 25
years ago freaking hot machine though
dude someone else took over right after
you left no but they saw the indian they
saw the indian kid with the usa jacket
and i'm like
guile
that's the right answer is that your
favorite character they were like this
[ __ ] didn't even choose
my mom almost got me kidnapped when i
was a kid we were like
yeah she brought so it was me my mom and
my dad i was like probably four and we
were going to circus circus and they had
like a big like boat in front of circus
circuits like those sweepstakes right
you fill that out and you enter to win
this boat or whatever so my mom was just
with me and i think she's trying to buy
popcorn and like or icys or whatever
because i'm gonna go watch the show and
she just realized she can't handle me
and the food so she's like uh
i'll put you in the boat
and then stay right here the boat's
really tall the kid's not going to get
out of the boat
so she goes i'm going to go
uh get snacks
she leaves
so i'm just in the boat somebody won the
boat
somebody won bart
i'm just in the boat and then the cops
come and they're like where are your
parents and i'm like oh i don't know i
think she's getting snacks or whatever
and then so they take me to the police
department oh no and you know when
you're a kid like you just think the
world's gonna end because you don't know
i'm not gonna talk to my mom like i
don't know anything and then so they
brought me into police department
and they were all just making jokes like
just as regular dudes are asian jokes no
no just like
no chinese
[Laughter]
do you speak english
no they're just doing that shade on this
kid's head
they're like do you want ramen
they're just being like regular dudes
right but i think when you're a kid and
you're like so like shrunk in your mind
every time someone laughs it sounds like
an evil that would ha
but they're just probably [ __ ] around
like bowser laughing
so they handled me
i don't run away and uh and i just
remember bawling in my eyes i was
swearing i'm never going to see my
parents ever again go to jail poor kid
thought he's getting arrested and then
finally my mom was able to come in and
find me just arms full of snacks yeah
[ __ ] like two hours later or some
[ __ ] and on my [ __ ] did you get your
ass whooped no i didn't how did she find
you
and the cops were like
we got him in the station we can't we
handcuffs into a chair he's not getting
anywhere i used to walk away so much
from my mom that i became friends with
like customer service at the
mall store like the local kmart and
walmart because i would just go up i
just walk away from my mom and then be
like hey
i don't know where my mom is can you
page dr rajan like it was doctor
and so then it would be like paging dr
rajan paging dr rajan dude that must be
so embarrassing for your mom like my mom
would show up and she's like you're
[ __ ] idiot like so when we used to go
to disney world after that she used to
just put me on a leash yeah i was gonna
say you had the leash at least yeah i
was on the lead
with the fire usa jumpsuit though but it
was like it was like the dog leash that
could like retract i think
so you have some wiggle room yeah i was
like
i love how they make whimsical designs
for those wishes to make it look like
not as bad like a little monkey with a
tail those are cool though it was funny
because she was very practical with my
mom she's like [ __ ] it i'm not gonna
look for you anymore yeah and then i
also knew my dad had a beeper because he
was always on call so you have a
memorized i had my mom's office number
memorized and my dad's beeper
memorized do you guys memorize any phone
numbers anymore except for your own no
no i do
right i know i know uh my house number i
know
my parents and my sister's cells you
have a house like a dialogue no like my
parents house oh okay yeah and then i
know my two best friends from like
elementary school i have oh dude it's
hard to forget those numbers yeah like
from when you were a kid and you had
friends i would say it but yeah say it
right now
[Laughter]
my mom's house number my dad's house
number
uh my mom's house number in taiwan
damn you oh taiwan you know different
country codes international code
that's just like 40 numbers dude that's
a bunch mr worldwide over here dude yeah
do you remember your credit card numbers
too no my driver's license number what
about your social security that i
remember but didn't your driver's
license change oh yeah not the new one i
haven't memorized a new one i remember
my childhood phone number
number do you call it sometimes i should
huh i'm gonna call so let's call right
now see someone picks up his kid's self
hola
college it's joe's child that's been
living under this you're gonna call him
you're gonna call him the number right
you finally have called alright here we
go
we're sorry sorry you have reached a
number that has been disconnected uh
when's the last time you heard that
though
oh i've heard that
they gave me flashbacks man i was like
oh [ __ ] i'm in trouble i gotta tell him
i got a [ __ ] d
[Music]
you